¿Es que republicana de Cataluña
se ha atrevido de hablar de 1 Tal
déficit fiscal de Cataluña
con el resto de España?
Dicen que ha llegado a su máximo,
a 22 000 millones de euros.
Cómo se calcula el beneficio de la economía catalana,
¿que exporta sus bienes
y sus servicios al resto de España?
Cómo se calculan
los servicios que el estado da a Cataluña,
como por ejemplo en defensa,
¿en acción exterior y muchísimos otros servicios?
Todo esto es populismo barato.
¿Es que republicana se parece
a la derecha más conservadora del Reino Unido
que usaba el mismo argumento del déjez fiscal
con la Unión Europea
para justificar el Brexit?
No se puede poner precio a ser español